I work with mr. cracker we did her
finale look for drag race
Madonna I've worked with her since I was
like 22 years old Nicki Minaj Amanda
Lepore Lady Bunny and another wonderful
Queen that I work with is miss fame I
did a lot of her finale looks we are a
custom design studio we pretty much
create anything from stage where to
Couture to Bridal to gloves hat it's
pretty much a place where anything is
possible I would say anything from her
last two special effects to movies
television high-fashion Couture to
anything that you could wrap your head
around and just make fabulous that's our
niche we will use anything from the most
delicate lace to the stiffest leather or
molded plastic all sorts of just like
synthetics because if you're doing
burlesque you're gonna be dropping that
thing on the floor non-stop and you
better be able to clean it the things
that inspire my work the first thing is
the person that I'm designing around I
take their essence and then I bring in
where I come from and I get a lot of my
inspiration from sci-fi growing up with
sci-fi as a kid nature never gets it
wrong which leads me into architecture
which is your right from nature fauna
dinosaurs you name it I can be inspired
by the shape of a light bulb one of my
favorite things are tearaway looks my
technique is usually to make the most
unexpected thing come off or the person
just pulls one little cord and the
entire thing just peels away to a
completely other look that's underneath
it this is Fred burlesque performer
named Eden Berlin and I just loved it so
much because I was thinking of like some
sort of like flora from outer space and
I really wanted her to like reveal
herself and slowly spin and like just
like be
looming out of this insanely like gray
thing and just Sparkle and then this
layer after layer after layer under this
[Music]
one of the most challenging burlesque
looks that I've done as of late is Jin
Minsky with my favorite clients and she
wanted to be a soft-serve ice cream cone
it peeled out of an ice an actual like
physical ice cream cone had a waffle
wrap she comes out of her waffle wrap
he continues to like take things off
amazing the audience until she ends up
in nothing but what looks like melted
pasties and g-strings as much as I love
to do stage wear and insane costumes I
would love to make it accessible to
everybody out there you feel like
dressing like a wasp woman or what have
you
one day we're all going to be able to
dress however we feel inside that will
be my time to shine
[Music]